- Il a fallu 20 ans de travail,
10 milliards $ et l'apport de
chercheurs américains, canadiens
et européens, mais le grand
télescope spatial James-Webb
devrait bientôt s'envoler à
partir du Centre spatial
européen, en Guyane française.
Ce sera le nouveau diamant de
l'astrophysique, une machine
extrêmement raffinée et ultra
performante.
RENÉ DOYON, chercheur principal
des incanadiens, ASC
- Jamais on aura construit
un télescope aussi grand, aussi
puissant dans l'espace, et pour
le Canada, c'est sans précédent:
jamais dans toute l'histoire du
programme spatial canadien
a-t-on été impliqué dans une
mission d'une telle envergure.-:
avec son miroir de 6,50 m et
ses instruments de pointe,
le nouveau télescope est
100 fois plus puissant que
le célèbre Hubble.
ÉRICK DUPUIS, dir. Développement
et exploration spatiale,
Agence spatiale canadienne- Jame
frapper l'imaginaire collectif
autant que Hubble.
- Alors que Hubble se concentre
sur la détection de la lumière
visible, le James-Webb
s'intéresse seulement au
rayonnement infrarouge,
invisible à l'oeil nu.
La détl'infrarouge
permet au télescope de voir à
travers les nuages de poussière
galactique et d'étudier des
phénomènes très froids et très
éloignés de nous, par exemple de
minuscules exoplanètes.
Ce que ne peut pas faire Hubble.
- En fait, on aurait beau avoir
le télescope le plus gra
monde dans le visible, on ne
verrait rien, les planètes,
elles sont dans l'infrarouge.
Et c'est pourquoi on a dû
uire un télescope
infrarouge.
- Le James-Webb transporte
trois instruments scientifiques.
Le Canada a conçu l'un d'entre
eux, le NIRISS, mais également
le système de guidage qui va
permettre au télescope de
pointer et de suivre ses cibles
dans l'immensité
- Ce système-là a une super
précision, on parle d'environ
d'un millionième de degrés.
Pour vous donner une idée,
à peu près l'épaisseur
d'un cheveu humain, même
un cheveu de bébé, à une
distance d'un kilomètre. Donc,
être capable de pointer
avec ce genre de précision-là.
- La principale mission du
James-Webb, c'est de recueillir
la lumière la plus ancienne
possible, celle produite par
les toutes premières ét
galaxies qui se sont formées
après le Big Bang.
- L'univers est âgé de
13,7 milliards d'années,
sait maintsait maintsait maintss
précisément. Et on sait que
les premières galaxies se sont
formées en quelques centaines de
millions d'années. Donc on va
regarder jusqu'à 13,5 milliards
d'années de la Terre. Donc,
c'est effectivement, Webb,
c'est une machine à remonter
dans le temps.
- Le télescope va également
s'intéresser de près
aux exoplanètes potentiellement
porteuses de vie.- Si- Si- Si- r
la composition chimique
des atmosphères des exoplanètes
et détecter soit des milieux
propices à la vie ou
des biomarqueurs qui seraient
des traces de vie, c'est classe
prix Nobel.
- Pour fonctionner, les
instruments du James-Webb
doivent se trouver dans un
environnement très sombre et
extrêmement froid, tout près
du zéro absolu. Le télescope va
donc être posté à un million et
demi dtres de tres de tres de t.
Dans six mois, si tout va bien,
il va recevoir et enregistrer
ce que les astronomes appellent
la "première lumière".
Après ça, tout est possible.
- Historiquement, lorsqu'on
regarde les grands télescopes
qu'on met en opération, soit sur
Terre ou au sol, dans l'espace,
on se pose la question: "Quelle
a été la principale découverte
que ces télescopes ont faite?"
ix ans après,
la réponse; on le sait pas,
c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas prévu.
Ici Normand Gro